hola soy rob jansen y soy animador antes
de que hablemos sobre la animación por
computadora algoritmos y todo eso
hablemos sobre qué es una animación en
su esencia cualquier animación está
basada en la misma idea hacer cambios a
una serie de imágenes y después
desplegar las rápidamente en secuencia
en la animación tradicional
hacemos esto con dibujos los animadores
dibujan posturas clave y después dibujan
una serie de imágenes a las que llamamos
intermedios que conectan el movimiento
de una pose a otra son muchos dibujos en
la animación digital animamos moviendo
un modelo virtual que llamamos paw sing
las poses que creamos son traducidas a
coordenadas que son registradas en una
hoja de cálculo y la computadora crea
las imagenes intermedias
estos intermedios son el resultado de la
computadora al interpretar el movimiento
de una imagen y su relación con tal o
cual pose claro que la computadora no
puede actuar así que solo nos da esto
luego refinamos los intermedios para
convertir este movimiento robótico en
algo más natural como esto
existen diferentes formas de llenar los
intermedios pero cada una puede
describirse usando una función
matemática llamada spline y aquí es
donde las matemáticas se encuentran con
el arte la forma más simple de ver esto
es con una pelota que rebota haré que
rebote de aquí hasta acá formando poses
que definió usando cuadros clave la
computadora evalúa el spline y dibuja el
resto de las imágenes
después la computadora hace una
interpolación lineal del movimiento y
así obtenemos algo que se mueve a una
velocidad constante
gracias a la física sabemos que la
pelota debería acelerar al caer y
desacelerar al subir así que voy a
ajustar la forma del spline para cambiar
el tiempo ahora tenemos algo más
realista pero aún así es muy genérico
como animador mi trabajo es darle vida a
un personaje específico para eso me hago
algunas preguntas la pelota es pesada y
está triste como esto o tal vez está
feliz tal vez es un globo una vez que
respondo a estas preguntas puedo elegir
qué tipo de curva creo que debería dar
ese efecto al movimiento y esto se
vuelve más emocionante cuando vemos un
personaje y su física porque la forma en
la que se mueve dice mucho de quién es
por ejemplo para esta escena de mister
increíble la animación debe mostrarlo
levantando el vagón de un tren ahora en
animación eso lo podemos hacer rápido y
fácil pero el director no quería eso él
quería que la audiencia supiera que
mister increíble podría realizar cosas
grandiosas pero que le costaban trabajo
así que la forma en que definimos la
velocidad de los intermedios hace la
diferencia entre que el tren parezca
ligero o pesado
entonces seamos claros la computadora
nos ayuda muchísimo pero ultimadamente
este trabajo es sobre actuación solo que
en lugar de estar frente a la cámara
la actuación y la deshace en incrementos
muy pequeños de 24 fracciones por
segundo expresando los en funciones
matemáticas abstractas está genial no